we'll come to the party politics a
moment but i just want to start with
some of the
uh wider issues that i discussed with
deputy prime minister um
is labour satisfied that the
government's doing all it can
uh in the circumstances including having
sent weapons and personnel to ukraine
about the russian threat
i think that what's really important is
and putin knows this he has an absolute
nose for it is that we have to be
completely unified on this we have to be
strong and we have to be unified whether
it's within at nato or surrounding
allies and we have to play our part as
the opposition also in making sure that
in britain we stand unified against this
threat because in the end we putin will
take advantage of any disunity and any
weakness that we show so yes we stand
with the government on this we think
that we absolutely need to this uh it is
outrageous the threats that uh putin is
making the claims that he's trying to
make in terms of telling ukraine what it
should do in the future and we need to
stand up to it but i'll tell you what i
think also
is i don't think that we use sanctions
as well as we could do i think that we
could be much more imaginative in the
way that we do there are many there is a
new generation of sanctions out there
which to be honest the province
well
there's a there's a power for example to
go for for for wealth that can't be
explained unexplained wealth and there
are many russian citizens in britain at
the moment who have unexplained wealth
you know we ought to be much stronger on
that we ought to be much stronger when
it comes to making sure that party
donations are completely tight we have
to make sure that that anybody in the
house of commons or in the lords who are
sitting on any foreign companies ought
to be on any for foreign company boards
ought to be or to have that register of
of interest there's a whole lot of
things that we could do in terms of
tightening up potential influence in
britain but also making sure that we are
not the laundering capital of the world
i i get all of that but um
let's be honest mr putin doesn't seem to
give much weight
to appeal to his better nature or indeed
um to
financial threats to any of his friends
so what would you actually do to
forestall and invite an invasion well i
don't know about financial threats to
his friends and not taking that
seriously i don't think that we have
been particularly serious in terms of
the financial threats to the friends i
think that's the point i think
absolutely you know if we threatened his
friends we may well be threatening his
money as well i do think this is a new
generation of sanctions this is a new
way in which you can do foreign policy
very effectively and i think that we're
not imaginative enough and we're not
strong enough in terms of the way in
which we use it okay as a shadow
attorney general what do you make of
this rather extraordinary statement by
the foreign office
naming people that it thinks could be
part of a puppet regime in kiev
well we do know that uh that putin has
been trying to
meddle in the affairs of ukraine for a
long time and indeed more than that you
know when he invaded part of ukraine and
we continue to have cyber attacks um in
ukraine and so therefore any attempt to
influence you know future politics in
ukraine is absolutely goes absolutely
hand in hand with that but that's why as
i said at the outset it's so important
that we are strong and that we
remain united against the threat from
putin because that's what he goes for
i'm being told that in fact the russians
have actually responded to this
statement they call it disinformation
and uh an escalation of tensions uh but
by the west well there we are
i mean uh sorry but i just like we just
have to stand up to these people
okay well uh maybe uh at some point
we'll we'll see uh emily thornberry
versus vladimir putin
now i the point is is not that the point
is it may be vladimir putin versus a
united west that's what's important
um covid the royal college of general
practitioners uh chair says this morning
that uh forcing health staff to be
vaccinated should be delayed and it's
not the right way forward do you agree
i think that whatever we decide we got
to do we really ought to be working on
the basis of working with those within
the health service and within the union
movement so if we decide that it's a
better idea to
to to put this measure off then as i say
so long as we're working with others on
it we just need to move forward together
on this yeah but that
when we actually disagree it's not
possible to move forward that point of
politics is decide what you should do
do you do you think that those who as uh
the deputy prime minister said those who
will not be vaccinated working in the
health service because they might put
others in danger should then lose their
jobs
the principle behind that i'm afraid we
do agree with but the question is when
should that policy be implemented there
is discussion about putting off the
deadline in relation to that and and if
we're going to put off the deadline then
we need to work with the hospitals and
with the trade union movement about how
it is that we can convince as many
people as possible who work within the
health service to get themselves
vaccinated nobody works in the national
health service who doesn't come into the
service not for the money but in order
to make sure they help others and you
know and arguments need to be put before
them to say you're not helping others by
not being vaccinated all right well
let's deal with um some of the uh wider
issues that are discussed with the the
deputy prime minister the economy
particularly can i confirm that um
labour wants the government to drop its
planned rise in national insurance
and also to fed forbid any rise in the
level of the energy price cap that's
what we want to do is we want to cut vat
on on on energy because to be honest the
government has had a bit of a windfall
because you know obviously as prices go
up they get more vat out of it so we're
saying you know drop the v80 that will
that will result in hundreds of pounds
being available to families we also want
to be able to have a windfall tax on the
energy companies who themselves are also
making much greater profits as a result
and we want that money to be targeted on
the squeeze middle on the poorest on on
pensioners to make sure that they're
given assistance with their energy it's
all fully costed we're really surprised
the government doesn't have a plan but
as the opposition we're helping them out
we've got a plan we've put it on the
table we said here i use this what are
you helping them out this is
a bit puzzling label party wants to stop
a tax right that being a percentage of
income is
by its nature it's the wealthier hardest
you
want to um
stop their their vat
change you also by the way want to keep
the bbc license fee which is a flat tax
all of these are regressive
measures i mean um when did the labour
party
part of redistribution become
in favor of regressive taxation well i
don't think that the national insurance
tax is
is as you as you describe i think one of
the most important things about the
national insurance tax is that it's a
tax on jobs and there's a tax on
employers and if we want to have full
employment we need to make we need to
make life as well you have to pay it too
yeah absolutely but it's also a tax on
it's a tax on jobs it you know it's a
it's a disincentive for employers to
take on more people if this can't be
right at a time at a time like this you
know these are the reasons behind the
decisions that we've made and it's not
regressive what we've said in relation
to energy as we've said there's a two
everybody's going to have their bills
largely increased by 50 percent you know
just in a few months time the government
just seems to be like rabbits in the
headlights just standing there thinking
oh my goodness we're about to get run
over but we what we need to do is we
need to do something about it so we've
said get rid of v80 that will help
everyone but then also have this
targeted money which would be available
for the poorest all right well look
let's um let's let's deal with uh this
is a politics show let's deal with
politics um you have uh
you know in in your own way uh spent a
lot of this conversation telling me
about
what the shortcomings of this government
um last week your colleague where
streeting told me that you wouldn't move
a vote of no confidence because in the
in parliament because uh you didn't
think you'd have the numbers
i don't get this if he's as bad for the
nation as you're always saying he is
well first of all what does that tell
you about the parliamentary party he
leads
well look
they have a majority of 80. that's why
in the end it isn't for the opposition
to and the prime minister ought to be so
terrible not all of those conservatives
are people without conscience why can't
you bring them across to your side for
this point well we're doing our bit
we're doing our best we are making it
perfectly clear what our criticisms are
we're making the argument as to why this
prime minister is totally unfit to
continue to be at number 10 and the
latest allegations about it
we are doing our best to try and tear
them out but they do have a majority of
80 and in the end although the although
the prime minister is answerable to
parliament the parliament is skewed in
that they have a majority of 80. so
there is a great deal in the the prime
minister's future rests in his own
conscience he can make his own decision
but then next it is for tory mps to
decide whether or not they want to
continue to support him and we continue
to to to put the argument as to why it
is and frankly so do the public i mean
most tory mps get large numbers of
letters from members of the public
saying do the right thing
push this prime minister out so first of
all we need to we i would i would
encourage backbench mps to put the
letters in and then you know we will
hear from sue gray let's take these
things step by step all right just very
quickly uh one thing they will always
say about emily thornberry is that she's
a realist isn't the real truth here that
actually a wounded boris johnson is
better for you than boris johnson gone
without with a better leader
i think that boris johnson wounded boris
johnson full stop as prime minister does
this country no good and that's why we
want to get rid of him